certainly no need to activate Skywarn
spotters today no I'd the winds
yesterday might have needed those
because they were pretty rough in some
neighborhoods like the southeast Valley
but the good thing is all those rough
winds really calmed down a lot by
daybreak today temperatures are
beautiful out there really get out and
enjoy the morning the afternoon won't be
too hot either and that's the good news
we had a lot of 70s right now we still
have a few breezes out there and the
winds are shifting direction behind a
cold front and that's going to help cool
us off even a little bit more today 81
by 9:00 o'clock 89 by noon and our
afternoon high at just 94 that cold
front associated with that system that's
bringing rain and snow up into the Great
Basin so Northwest breezes today maybe
20 25 miles an hour and that helps chip
away at even more heat we're only
talking 94 today for June 95 and less
wind tomorrow right back to some hot
triple digits though by the weekend a
welcomed summer on Saturday dad's day
looks hot at 106 107 next week